[Music]
what makes something fake news
I would assume if the news being
reported is fake or wrong and the person
presenting that news knows it is fake or
wrong that is bad but what if the news
being reported is accurate the facts are
good they just sound bad my colleague
Chris Wallace has discovered again the
president doesn't distinguish apparently
furious over Chris's interview this past
weekend with House Minority Whip Steve
Scalise Scalise has steadfastly defended
the president on this whole Ukrainian
situation the president likes Steve for
that let's just say he doesn't like
Chris for challenging Scalise on that
like when Scalise dismissed the first
week of public appearing says Adam
shifts witnesses chris pointed out say
what you will of those witnesses they
were career foreign service officers who
worked in the Trump administration or
when Scalise argued the president was
only concerned about corruption in
Ukraine even though Chris pointed out
the president never uttered the word
corruption in that July 25th call I'll
call that Scalise said involves only the
two presidents but as chris quickly
added yeah and a dozen people listening
in and a number of them immediately
upset now we can debate whether the
crime was committed here or any crime
was committed here but Chris challenged
Scalise concluding the witnesses who
testified last week didn't see a crime
committed here that was his view of what
they said but that is not what they said
passions run deep these days but facts
should run even deeper even if those
very facts can elicit wildly different
reactions some insisting they exonerate
the president and others just as adamant
that they all but indict the president
it's a pity the president didn't stick
around to catch Chris just as
aggressively going after Democratic
congressman and Intelligence Committee
member Jim Himes and the lack of any
firsthand evidence implicating the
president in anything now while it's
understandable not to like what you hear
mr. president it is not understandable
to tune out what you should otherwise
like very much to hear including plenty
of coverage of markets that are soaring
in an economy that is humming Chris has
covered that I have covered that Fox
News and Fox Business which if you don't
get mr. president you should demand
not just some of it mr. president all of
it the things you like and yes the
things you might not like you are not
the first president to say the media has
it out for you no less than press
darling John F Kennedy himself had his
moments with the media people will
always see things through the prism of
their own set of beliefs I get that just
like I get plenty of Trump supporters
who call me a never Trump er for getting
into batters they don't like and plenty
of never Trump is themselves for giving
any credit to a president they will
never like we can't please all the best
we could do as journalists is be fair to
all including you mr. president that's
not fake doing that what is fake is not
doing that what it's fake it's saying
Fox never used to do that mr. president
we have always done that we did Kristen
I know I did
I recall quite well a chat I had with
you back in 2015 when you were running
for president I heard later on that you
were none to plays actually called me
nasty the interview even worse you were
entitled to that opinion mr. president
actually meant he agreed with you then
many agree with you now some go so far
as to say I'm fat and clueless mr.
president now imagine anyone calling me
fat but journalists no matter their
weight aren't entitled to praise you we
are obligated to question you and always
be fair to you we will even if it risks
inviting your wrath like I said you are
free to rage oh we are free to do is
report and let the viewers decide we
started out that way will continue being
that way good night
you